BRIAN: THOUSANDS OF PROTESTERS
FLOOD MICHIGAN STATE’S CAPITAL
OVER THE GOVERNOR’S STAY-AT-HOME
ORDER.
LISTEN.
>> INSTEAD OF LOOKING AT
ESSENTIAL AND NONESSENTIAL,
LET’S START LOOKING AT WHAT IS
SAFE AND UNSAFE AND START
GETTING PEOPLE BACK TO WORK.
>> QUARANTINE IS FOR THE SICK
NOT FOR THE HEALTHY.
>> IT’S TIME TO OPEN UP.
>> WE’RE GOING TO TAKE OUR
LIBERTIES AND WE ARE GOING TO
KEEP THEM AND WE’RE GOING TO
FIGHT FOR THEM.
BRIAN: THE ORDER IS THE
STRICTEST IN THE NATION PUSHES
BACK ON FAMILY VISITS.
CAN’T EVEN GO TO YOUR OWN SUMMER
HOUSE.
CAN’T USE A JET SKI.
CAN’T USE A MOTOR BOAT BUT CAN
USE A CANOE.
BRING IN THE HOST OF LIBERTY
FILE ON FOX NATION JUDGE ANDREW
NAPOLITANO.
JUDGE, THESE RESTRICTIONS ARE
RIDICULOUS AND THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE CAME OUT TO PROTEST.
DOES IT SURPRISE YOU?
>> IT SURPRISES ME THAT IT TOOK
THEM THIS LONG TO COME OUT,
BRIAN.
GOOD MORNING.
>> BLATANT VIOLATION OF THE BILL
OF RIGHTS.
BLATANT VIOLATION OF A RIGHT TO
ASSEMBLY.
PURCHASE OF A PRODUCT THAT YOU
DECIDE IS ESSENTIAL.
IF YOU GO TO A BIG BOX STORE IN
MICHIGAN, AND YOU DECIDE INSTEAD
OF BUYING CEREAL I WANT TO BUY
GRASS SEED.
INSTEAD OF BUYING PAPER TOWELS
INSTEAD OF GARDEN HOSE HAVE YOU
VIOLATED THE GOVERNOR’S
EXECUTIVE ORDER AND
THEORETICALLY BECAUSE SHE HAS
THREATENED TO DO THIS, SHE WILL
SHUT DOWN THE BIG BOX STORE
BECAUSE THEY SOLD YOU GRASS SEED
AND A GARDEN HOSE INSTEAD OF
CEREAL AND PAPER TOWELS.
THESE ARE NOT DECISIONS FOR THE
GOVERNMENT TO MAKE.
THESE ARE DECISIONS FOR
INDIVIDUALS TO MAKE.
AND THE SOONER WE TAKE OUR
FREEDOMS BACK.
THE LESS LIKELY THE GOVERNMENT
WILL BE ABLE TO CONTINUE DOING
THIS.
IF WE DON’T TAKE OUR FREEDOMS
BACK THEY MIGHT NOT COME BACK.
BRIAN: IT’S GETTING TOUGH NOW
WASN’T THE ONLY PLACE THERE WERE
PROTESTS.
LET ME LET YOU HEAR.
THIS IS GOVERNOR WHITMER HAS
IMPOSED AS OVERSTEPPING OTHER
AUTHORITY.
THIS IS ACCORDING TO THE
PROTESTER.
SHE HAS CREATED A VAGUE
FRAMEWORK OF EMERGENCY LAWS ONLY
CONFUSE MICHIGAN CITIZENS AS A
RESULT WE WILL NOT HAVE STRICT
ENFORCEMENT OF THESE ORDERS.
SO THEY’RE NOT GOING TO COMPLY.
GUESS WHERE ELSE THEY’RE
PROTESTING?
THEY ARE PROTESTING IN KENTUCKY,
OHIO, NORTH CAROLINA, AND
VIRGINIA.
AND AS MORE AND MORE STATES GO
ONLINE AND GET THEIR RIGHTS
BACK, THAT IS GOING TO FUEL, I
BELIEVE, OTHER STATES TO GO WAIT
A SECOND.
THIS IS GETTING RIDICULOUS.
HAVE YOU GOT 29 STATES WITHOUT A
BIG IMPRINT FROM THIS VIRUS.
DON’T YOU THINK THAT’S WHERE IT
IS HEADING, JUDGE?
>> I DO THINK THAT’S WHERE IT’S
HEADING.
YOU KNOW, HERE IN NEW JERSEY,
THE GOVERNOR BOASTS, IT BOASTED
TO TUCKER CASUAL SON RIGHT NOW
THE BILL OF RIGHTS IS ABOVE MY
PAY GRADE.
THE BILL OF RIGHTS IS ABOVE YOUR
PAY GRADE?
YOU TOOK A SOLEMN OATH TO
PRESERVE, DEFEND AND PROTECT THE
CONSTITUTION OF THE UNITED
STATES WHICH INCLUDES THE BILL
OF RIGHTS WHEN THESE GOVERNORS
TRY TO WRITE LAW RATHER THAN
ENFORCE LAW THAT THE LEGISLATURE
HAS WRITTEN, THEY VIOLATE THE
FEDERAL CONSTITUTION.
THEY VIOLATE THE STATE
CONSTITUTION.
AND IN THE CASE OF GOVERNOR
MURPHY IN NEW JERSEY WHO SAYS
THE BILL OF RIGHTS IS ABOVE HIS
PAY GRADE, THAT’S A FELONY OF
MISCONDUCT IN OFFICE.
IT’S AN IMPEACHABLE OFFENSE FOR
A GOVERNOR TO EITHER KNOWINGLY
OR NEGLIGENTLY TO CRASH CIVIL
LIBERTIES AS THESE GOVERNORS
HAVE DONE.
>> I HAVE SPOKEN TO COPS.
THEY HATE WHAT THE GOVERNORS ARE
MAKING THEM DO.
MOST OF THE COPS I HAVE SPOKEN
TO THEIR HEARTS ARE WITH THE